boomerang again did you yes so many
people fall in love with you know
wouldn't we first put it out we were
like alright if this could get a million
views or even like ten million views oh
my gosh could you imagine forgot 10
million and now with over 600 million
like it's crazy I don't even get it and
like to this day like it's still my
number one like it still gets 500,000
views every single day and it's been out
for almost three years like that's
mind-blowing it's crazy and what I love
about it too is the song has such a
empowering definitely it's unimportant
to you do include hundred percent 100
percent you know all my songs have that
message behind it some of them you just
have to look a little farther for it but
boomerang is just right there and it's a
hundred percent important to me for all
my songs to be happy and positive and
upbeat
DRD a.m. is the latest song and video
yes tell me about making that video that
was really fun I it was it was a good
day on set you know it was awesome a lot
of my friends were in it it was the
first second music video I guess that
Bobo wasn't in us I missed her on set it
was so fun you know Richie Jackson was
the choreographer of it he's on fire
right now I mean he's Lady Gaga's
choreographer he was in a star is born
he did the choreography for a star was
born so super cool to have him in on the
music video and maybe even it on
something else big project that I'm
doing but I don't know I mean that's
cool the tour logos behind me I didn't
say anything what are you talking about
well i'll talk to dr i am is a song but
i mean are you living your dream right
now because I am literally yeah did you
ever expect when you were little that
this would actually come to fruition
because what you're doing right now is
the dream of so many yes is literally
this was my dream like this was what I
want to do and like especially going on
tour like specifically that's like
something I always wanted to do and now
like that that's my reality then I mean
I've worked so hard for it but like
that's just like doesn't happen it but
like it really shows that it does happen
like you can do what you put your mind
to
absolutely what else are you still
dreaming about right now there's always
goals we sell so many things so many
things I even going on this tour now I
want to go on a world tour so I want to
go everywhere in the world yeah no
there's so many more things I wanna do
in life
are you excited to come to Canada oh yes
a mate have you been before to Canada I
have I've been to Canada I went to
Toronto and I went to Vancouver I filmed
a movie in Vancouver my Nickelodeon
movie so that was cool
well let's talk I want to talk a little
bit about lip sync battle shorties yes
so much fun how much fun are you having
on that series
it's so awesome getting to it with Nick
Cannon like it's it's such a great set
to be around you know there's so many
kids all the dancers so fun like I've
been on a lot of sets and that was just
like fine it's just so fun yeah a nick
is awesome I mean help collective work
he's great he's so funny and now he's
like the like the coolest like he knows
exactly where he's going but then like
my station station like the DJ booth
that I said it has like so many buttons
like every time he comes over it's like
do a shot over there he's like I like
play with all my buttons is like a kid
but he's awesome his kids are adorable
he brought them to set either so funny
the coolest kids I've ever met yeah no
he's great what uh have you had anybody
surprising reach out to maybe some kind
of celebrities that you were like wow I
can't believe this person knows who I
guess Wiz divani
that was really cool we were at a New
York event and at the time now I love
Spencer Prince funny I know every song I
love her but at the time I just knew her
as the girl who sang holla back girl
like I didn't know like she was this
huge person who had all these amazing
it's so like they were like hey Gwen
Stefani's here you wanna take picture
with her and I was like yeah sure and I
went over and she's like oh my gosh like
can I take a picture with you and like
before I could even ask her like she's
like pointing me out I was like sure
like I didn't really know much about her
but now I'm looking back at that I'm
like wow that's crazy but she gave me
great advice that I would literally
never forget but I've never told anybody
I can't tell Oh secret I know it's a
thing it's uh it's a thing it's a thing
but no um Channing Tatum and Jenna Dewan
when I was at the Kids Choice Awards and
I was walking out to perform they had
their kid and they were walking out and
it's like we passed and he chanting went
oh my Jojo like the girl you like and I
literally just hi and like I kept
walking I was like that was Channing
Tatum so then Jenna Dewan I saw on her
Instagram story her kid was found my
book I think son I reached out now like
I text her I've been her kid birthday
videos just stuff like
that there's been so many cool people
who was the basketball player LeBron
James LeBron James kid dances to my
music a lot we see that a lot Justin
Bieber sisters I see them a lot dancing
to my music so it's crazy like it's so
cool that is pretty crazy awesome you
know what when I told people I was
coming here Tuesday there were a lot of
parents that were really jealous of me
coming here love that it's so much
support about you they're like you know
she's such a positive role model my
daughter she's not trying to be somebody
who's 25 it definitely is it is you know
it bugs me I saw something like what 14
year olds I like back in the day and
what they're like now and I'm like
that's so sad because 14 you have to be
allowed to be 14 9 to be allowed to be 9
and I think that kids should be allowed
to be what they want to be and you know
for me I was their kid in my life like I
love being a kid you know I'm sure one
day when I'm 25 I'm gonna be like
alright I'm an adult like this is cool
but for now I'm a kid I'm enjoying my
life I want all kids to be kids for
forever and always